vous avez oublié votre porte monnaie
madame madame votre porte monnaie
c'est trop gros danger trop gros trop
donc se sont petit à quelques matchs je
le joue moins glauque sein d'un 4 go
elle est trop bas niveau c'est un
extrait de la toute première saison d
audition avec simon oui est de retour
sur m6 est de retour après six ans
d'absence pour une quatrième saison en
audition avec simon sera de retour à
partir de mardi sur ici tout point tv
c'était la toute première sirois série
web sur ici tout point tv en 2010 avec
un concept qui nous a tout de suite
accroché très simple simon olivier
fecteau et étienne de passillé qui font
passer les auditions des personnalités
connues les personnages les plus connus
du québec simon olivier qu'on veux
égorger et les prétentieux il est
insupportable
je parle de son personnage dans la série
bien sûr etienne à côté de lui même si
son souffre douleur il fait ce qu'il
peut
la série s'est terminée en 2012 mais en
2014 on a eu droit à un épisode spécial
dans l'audition avec simon c'est le
comédien benoît cliché qui était atteint
d'un cancer du cerveau que contacter
simon olivier fecteau qui lui a dit je
vais mourir bientôt si certains mais mon
rêve avant de mourir c'est de participer
à une émission spéciale de en audition
avec simon simon olivier qui à repartir
la machine qui a écrit un épisode
spécial avec comme thème le cancer
en voici un extrait très peu de moelleux
la truck sont sur le banc des pâquis
seule ma tumeur cancéreuse et on
travaille et c'est ça se passe que nous
autres on tourne l'été prochain
le nommé politique comme l'eau lors
l'été bazana avec je peux pas vraiment
tourner si t'es pas pourquoi et mais
c'était pour c'est pas ici ne parle pas
le propos parmi nous dans l'épisode doux
et amer émouvant drôle benoît cliché
décédé au début du mois de janvier 2015
ce qui a changé avec cette nouvelle
saison 2 en audition avec simon qu'on va
découvrir
mardi c'est le milieu de l'humour en
général et le mouvement moi aussi simon
olivier explique qu'on ne pourrait plus
faire certains épisodes et d'un exemple
de l'épisode avec julie le breton qu'on
a découvert en 2010 lors de la première
saison
le but de cet épisode là c'était que
simon olivier et étienne invite julie le
breton lui faisait miroiter un rôle mais
le but c'était de l'embrasser tout
simplement est dit on ne pourrait plus
faire c'est aujourd'hui ce qui a changé
il dit c'est plus facile d'inviter deux
grandes vedettes féminines québécoise à
l'époque on confiait peut-être au québec
- d'un rôle important à des femmes
ça change et ça et les invités pour
cette nouvelle saison 75% des invités
sont des femmes magalie lépine blondeau
guylaine tremblay charlotte cardin donc
on va pouvoir découvrir ces nouveaux
épisodes là à partir de mardi sur ici
tout point tv trois épisodes au départ
mardi
et puis il y en aura douze en tout oui
on va regarder ça et ce récit tou.tv
d'autres suggestions semaine de relâche
certains c'est la femme qui s'en vient
pour les autres vous avez puisque ce
sont les rendez-vous québec cinéma il ya
une dizaine de courts métrages qui sont
disponibles sur ici tout point tv
gratuitement je donne deux exemples pour
vous montrer à quel point c'est
diversifié la maison du hérisson d'un
court métrage de louannec absolument
charmant pour toute la famille et puis
les deuxième court métrage une
adaptation d'une bd de viviane qui
montre deux amants qui vivent leur amour
secret dans un chalet donc ça vous donne
à quel point ici de tout pour tous les
goûts sur ici tout point tv à la fois en
audition avec simon et tous ses courts
métrages et pour la semaine de relâche
j'en connais des petits à la main
don qui compte les dodos à tarbes est en
congé alors